[Musik]
das ding ist jetzt das feste feiern
andere und herzlich willkommen bei einem
neuen video ja ich habe mir natürlich
jedes gut ihr habt vermutlich schon
ersten tag dieses videos gesehen
echteste 10 1 euro produkte von juden
produkte ähnlich wie bayerisch die
ziemlich günstig waren so kleine gadgets
die einen kann man mehr brauchen gern
weniger deswegen test wird auch falls
ihr den ersten partner nicht gesehen
habt check den gerne erstmal ab heute
machen wir weiter mit den weiteren
szenen die noch übrig sind also ich habe
ich insgesamt 20 oder 21 stück bestellt
und die hälfte davon haben wir schon weg
oder fast die hälfte ich glaube wir uns
sogar noch ein bisschen mehr als die
hälfte
und ja das mache heute kanal abonnieren
jeden tag 19 uhr neues video
und das ist ja ganz ganz wichtig wird
damit ihr auch immer auf dem neuesten
stand bleibt und wir auf eure ideen für
weitere videos in die kommentare stellen
können so jetzt erstmals erst mal hin
auf jeden fall heute geplant dass hier
sind alles sachen dass insgesamt zehn
stück die waren eigentlich ein gefragt
und so jung papier könnt ihr im ersten
part 10
ich habe dir jetzt allerdings schon
ausgepackt genauso wie dieses produkt
das habe ich schon ganz ausgepackt und
zwar im ersten part das problem war nur
als wir das gedreht haben wir hatten
keine orange parat und wir brauchten
eine orange und deswegen habe ich jetzt
einen gekauft und wir probieren das
jetzt mal aus ich bin gespannt weil ich
muss sagen so es ist so eine orangene
kann er sein dass man das auch anders
und hiervon million zu regeln definitiv
nein
auf jeden fall muss ich sagen ich mache
orangen als ist eine super leckere
frucht ist so eine frucht was man zieht
das ding hier halt über einen finger und
kann das jetzt ganz entspannt hier wohl
durchziehen ist ja deutlich besser als
wenn man das mit der hand hält das kann
ja auch dann immer so ein bisschen
spritzen und so deswegen mal gucken ich
bin mal gespannt wir probieren das jetzt
einfach mal
ja eigentlich ganz gut also ich bin mir
halt gerade unsicher ob komplett die
ganze schule dafür damit abgeht
ich mache jetzt einfach mal so ein paar
umdrehungen naja ich weiß dass sich aus
an der orange liegt aber das natürlich
ein bisschen blöd ich würde mal so sagen
es ist ganz nett und man so ein anfang
zu machen um die orangen hat stehen zu
können aber so wirklich sinnvoll ist es
nicht weil man hat überall so reden drin
ist dann aber logischerweise sich von
alleine ab sondern man muss noch
deutlich nach hinten
also ich muss sagen sondern weil ich so
langsam wie noch nie gesehen naja
vielleicht ist es ja bei mandarin diesen
kleinen orangen leichter aber ja also
ich würde sagen eigentlich kann man so
was also ist unnötig braucht man nicht
ich hatte wirklich darauf dass die
schade dann ganz entspannt abgeht aber
gerade die orange leider mir strich
durch die rechnung gemacht sagt auch am
modell dieser orange
wer weiß mahnung weiter jetzt kann man
wieder ein paar sachen auspacken die
orange lässt sich gleich natürlich weil
es gesund vitamin c was da drin ganz
viel weiß was es ist
leute ich glaube das habe ich für 90
cent erschossen milch rasant supercool
also man kann auf jeden fall nicht
meckern das steckt man ins iphone rein
zumindest in den neuen iphone-modelle
hat dann mir einmal den zugang führt zum
beispiel kopfhörer und hier den zugang
zum laden weil das ist ja meistens das
problem dass man nicht gleichzeitig
laden und musikern kann mit kabel
kopfhörer also daraus für ich sagen top
feature bastionen und perfekt rein
sollte das jetzt testen oder ist das
unnatürlich wird schon funktionieren ich
habe mir das auch für mich selber
bestellt weil ich so was brauche für
dieses handy noch ich habe keinen
alkohol also ich besuche benutzt man
manchmal airports aber ich habe auch
kabel kopfhörer deswegen falls es nicht
funktionieren sollte werde jetzt sehen
es funktioniert nicht weil ihr dann
steht funktioniert nicht weil ich sonst
schon probiert habe dann steht ihr aber
auch natürlich auszuprobieren
wir machen weiter
[Applaus]
ich habe vor dem ersten part gesagt ich
habe einfach am ende nur noch
irgendwelche sachen die einen euro
gekostet haben in dem korb in den
warenkorb müssen wie zum beispiel auch
dieses ding wird
[Musik]
wie gut aus also ich habe extra dieser
haus des geldes maske ausgewählt das ist
die anonymous moskau ist es nicht aus
des bildes die anonymous gut kommt also
ich weiß auch nicht das hätte ich mir
sparen können um ehrlich zu sein weil
das ist kein mehrwert für euch und auch
keinen mehrwert für mich ja ich habe am
ende nur wirklich ich habe nichts mehr
gefunden und ich wollte unbedingt auf 20
produkte kommen bis jetzt das
langweiligste produkt von einst ist in
ordnung
leute bevor ich das jetzt weiter aus
packe ich habe schon super auch schon
den kommentaren gelesen alex was machst
du eigentlich mit diesem ganzen
produkten
ich muss ehrlich sagen vieles davon
liegt davor noch im schrank
allerdings ist es auch sehr sehr offen
freundlichen können oder so dass die
sich dann lenken
kassel das muss ich mitnehmen und das
kann natürlich jeder mitnehmen weil im
endeffekt findet es hier keine
verwendung deswegen so kleine gadgets
oder irgendwelche kleinen artikel sachen
dinge produkte wie auch immer geht
schneller weg als ihr denkt so lange
jemand spaß dran hat gerne
[Musik]
das ist ein geiles ding fast auf solche
mich zeigt wofür es gut ist man hat ja
ganz auf das problem dass man zum
beispiel so eine zahnpasta hat wie zum
beispiel diese hier das war irgendwie
sonne belegt zahnpasten vom aldi oder so
dann kommt halt dieses teile zum einsatz
das ist ganz gut hier ist jetzt auch
wirklich nicht mehr viel drin einiges
klebt noch nie hinten dann steckt man
das hier durch und optimalerweise müsste
man das jetzt genau
zack also ich würde sagen ist ganz in
ordnung die frage ist natürlich nur auch
man sowas weil man kann ja auch einfach
so machen und kann viel mehr kraft damit
auch denn als selber zu 16 domestiziert
an sich eine lustige idee also an dem
erfinder du bist auf jeden fall kreativ
ihr könnt ihr auch super gerne immer
kommentieren welches gadget euch am
besten gefällt damit jetzt absolut
gerade dieses hier für mein handy
das ist gut für ihn das habe ich extra
für dich bestellen weißt du warum du
beschwert sich doch immer weil hier
direkt neben uns ein spielplatz ist und
wenn man dann morgens noch schläft dass
die ganzen kinder darum schreiben
kindergärten kommt ein fahnder bobbycar
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht komm du
stellst du doch mal hier günstig für den
juli fahrer vor stöpsel
das sind nicht irgendwelche ohrstöpsel
das sind profis das noch nicht reichte
um die welt weiter ich habe einen schon
drin um die uns vernünftig zu verwenden
man muss sie einfach so ein bisschen
einräumen und das ist jetzt ein ganz
bestimmter stoff dann steckt man sich
jetzt ins ohr und dann gehen die wieder
aufgefüllt praktisch schon das ohr
auswahl das hört man's richtig bin
gleich mal gespannt ob ich noch etwas
höhere alter geil sagt hallo
ja also es ist auf jeden fall schon
deutlich langsamer geworden ich habe
schon mal so ein praktikum gemacht
sondern firma da gab es ja tonnenweise
diese dinge besser deswegen ich glaube
ich habe dafür ist so ein euro bezahlt
das wirkt irgendwie zu viel oder hat
schon so gut dass man das video so
weitermachen rede ich jetzt lauter
ok also noch ein feature was jetzt nicht
so die große aufmerksamkeit von mir
bekommt weil es halt einfach viel zu
teuer ist kann man auf jeden fall was
mit anfangen wenn ihre kinder vor der
tür stehen aber ansonsten braucht man
sowas im privathaushalt auch er nicht
mehr zu wir machen weiter da bin ich
jetzt ehrlich ich habe keine ahnung was
das ist aber ihr habt ja natürlich schon
eingeblendet kann man das essen
wahrscheinlich
[Musik]
also ich weiß auf jeden fall war für das
gedacht wird und zwar ich mal kurz den
kopf moment mal wir haben jetzt zum
beispiel wenn du hier rein films sieht
man ja wir sind noch ein paar ablagerung
ich weiß nicht genau was das war rost
würde ich jetzt mal nicht sagen er also
vom braten oder suchen ich hab es nicht
wegbekommen obwohl dreht man den kopf
überhaupt oder was auch immer und jetzt
macht man dieses ding hier glaube ich
ein bisschen nass ich jetzt bin ich mit
jemand gespannt ob das was bringt das
wert krass wenn das jetzt weg geht weil
ich saß da wirklich so fünf minuten dran
habt ihr geschrieben mit weg also ohne
spaß ist es nie im leben gedacht ja kann
man schon was geiles dringend bis jetzt
das beste feierlich anderer für alle da
kann ich euch wirklich nur empfehlen
wenn ihr mal irgendein problem habe im
haushalt wo auch immer und keine lösung
dafür findet geht einfach mal auf
irgendwelche von diesen webseiten jugend
durch kuranyi express keine ahnung was
wir noch haben googelt das problem und
vielleicht gibt's ja so ein kleines
gadget machst das entfernt oder was
dieses problem aus der welt schafft und
vielleicht klappt es damit dann sogar
jetzt zum beispiel in diesem fall kurz
ein paar sachen haben wir noch ich bin
mal gespannt
hast du eine ahnung was man was man hier
mitmacht so wichtig kein plan keine
ahnung was auch ich zeige dir denn damit
revolutionieren wir die fernsehwelt
das war ein bisschen übertrieben kannst
du die fernbedienung einpacken
weißt du wo mit geworben haben
die haben so eine stoffe gefärbt wird
gezeigt und dann so die dann so dieses
produkt hat als lösung und wenn die
fernbedienung hier drin ist es ist auch
so ein album produkte dann staubt die
nicht zu am moment falsch rum
wir haben uns hier die fernbedienung
drin und können trotzdem damit arbeiten
besser hier durch das sieht doch ein
hübsches ja also ich finds influenza
erheben also vor allem das design auch
hier hat den euro gekostet da kann man
doch
mehr kann ich meine es gibt bestimmt
viele leute die das kaufen ohne spaß zum
beispiel ich dieses produkt bis jetzt am
meisten auf jeden fall aber dann würde
ich eigentlich schon sagen kommt dass
hier oder neid nehmen natürlich die
zeitung dass auch leute machen aber
weiter
[Musik]
weil sie auch was das war und zwar ist
das halt für katzen wenn ihr eine katze
zu hause habt dieser maus dinge haben
will
zum spielen dann können wir euch das
kaufen ansonsten ich weiß nicht warum
nicht gestellt hat audi nicht kennst
irgendwie eine katze hat ja klitschko
kann er mitnehmen schenke ich ihnen
christa schenk ich dir dann kommen auch
schon zum vorletzten oder sogar letzten
produkt ich weiß es nicht ich weiß
gefühl da war und zwar der ist fürs auto
du kannst du dein spiegel machen feste
und dann wenn der blinker betätigt wird
link das soweit ich weiss also so stand
das auto ist das foto ist ja hier
angemeldet ich bin mir auch sicher dass
ist eine deutschen straßenverkehr gar
nicht erlaubt also das kann man halt
wohl im spiegel montieren ich habe das
gestellt weil ich dachte das ist so ein
ding was du dann an und ausschalten
kannst und hier dran freebsd und das
reflektiert einfach nur aber irgendwie
habe ich es falsch interpretiert
deswegen an sich was cool ist also ich
habe es noch nie gesehen hat irgendein
auto oder was suchst du warst schon mal
gesehen ist halt in deutschland safe
auch nicht erlaubt denke ich mal
aber ich kann es nicht anbringen ich hab
da einfach nicht die das fachwissen
führen und vor allem will ich auch
ungern an meinem auto herumschrauben
also falls ihr sowas für irgendwas
braucht es gibt so was aber auch man
braucht ist die andere frage
keine ahnung ich war mit dem ersten part
auf jeden fall mehr zufrieden da waren
interessante sachen dabei muss man ganz
ehrlich sagen auch lustige sachen
trotzdem hoffe ich dass euch dieses
video gefallen hat lass mir doch nach
oben da abonniert den kanal jeden tag 19
uhr neues video und instagram alex w ich
fahre jetzt auf klassenfahrt und dann
seht ihr das video wenn ich schon in
warschau bin wo wir das ganze dreht und
ja das war es von mir morgen 19 uhr
neues video kommt rein